les conséquences du surpeuplement des
sert à Saint-Bruno Serge Moquin et son
voisin Gérald montjo les constatent au
quotidien sur leur terrain depuis des
années
quelques tulipes ou un peu de nos
arbustes c'est pas grave mais qu'on est
de ce problème là chaque semaine cet
automne il pouvait y avoir jusqu'à 7
serres sur leur terrain moi ce qui une
des choses qui m'énerve beaucoup qui
m'inquiète c'est la tique ce que je
risque de poigner la maladie de Lyme
parce que je vais me promener sur mon
terrain là
c'est rendu là dans certains secteurs de
la Montérégie le surpeuplement des
populations de cervidés ont des effets
néfastes sur la biodiversité
l'équilibre au niveau des écosystèmes
est brisés par la surpopulation et on a
perdu une diversité fonctionnelle qui
est celle des prédateurs donc on est
dans l'obligation de d'occuper cette
niche là d'une certaine façon on va
venir modifier le règlement pour y
remédier le ministre Charette veut
modifier le règlement sur le port
d'armes pour autoriser la chasse à
l'arbalète dans les parcs nationaux
ce qui est déjà convenu par contre la
viande
issue de cette chasse là sera donné aux
organismes le ministre se dit conscient
de la sensibilité du sujet je trouve
cette geste de manque de respect du
système judiciaire pourtant le moment
est bien mal choisi pour mettre
Anne-France gauloister alors qu'elle
débat du sort des serres de Virginie du
parc Michel Chartrand à Longueuil cette
semaine en cours supérieur eux aussi
pourraient être abattu par arbalète
c'est une méthode particulièrement
cruelle de mise à mort d'un animal parce
que l'animal peut prendre plusieurs
minutes à plusieurs heures
derrière pierre roi n'est pas d'accord
moi je chasse à leur balade depuis des
années la mort se fait de façon très
rapide on parle de de moins d'une minute
le facteur qui est quand même très
efficace puis qui la souffrance au
niveau des animaux et très mignonne
la Ville de Boucherville n'est pas en
faveur de la chasse mais plutôt de la
stérilisation des femelles mais pour
plusieurs citoyens comme Serge et Gérald
le temps qui passe ne fait qu'empirer le
problème ici jacauderie Charbonneau
Radio-Canada Montréal